then can you share some tips that Joe
gave you not just about screenwriting in
general but about really pouring your
heart into the script just pouring your
whole life into it you know one of the
one of the main I think one of the
things that Joe really taught me was it
was trust your instincts that was one of
the biggest thing as a writer and and be
true to the story be true to yourself
and put everything on paper or now these
days on a laptop you know so yeah what
was that process like for you it was
hard it was tough because the story's so
personal it took a long time I mean this
has been over over ten years so it's you
know when you have something that's
related to your family about losing a
brother and for me also losing a
daughter and it's all if every single
one of these characters is someone that
I grew up with was related to my family
and also the neighborhood so it's it's
tough it was a process you found myself
at times even when I was writing the
memoir after a few pages you get
emotional you know it's really hard but
you gotta you gotta you gotta work
through it and Joe was always there for
me do you to almost have like a
shorthand with each other where you
already know what he's gonna say and
you've already answered it oh yeah I
mean I think that you know like with any
with any great friendship you know you
you develop a way of speaking to one
another way of interacting and you know
and and and you know it's like it's like
my brother and I it's the same thing you
know we have this that we have these
kind of this these inside jokes that
that we're laughing at that other people
find obnoxious because they don't know
you know what I mean because that
shorthand you know doesn't exist I don't
understand that but there's always you
know almost 20 years of knowing somebody
and spend any time with them so there is
that and I think there is a there is a
they like mindedness and bananas artists
I think wewe enjoy we're striving for
the same things you know we don't want
this kind of these kind of artificial
experiences and we wanted to make El
Chicano something that was not only
singular and its kind of vision but also
in its unique sense of family unique
sense unique kind of emotional journey
that the character goes on that that I
thought
we both thought was very necessary and
that's kind of what we strove for how
usual or unusual is it for someone to
spend what 20 years behind the camera
then getting their chance to direct or
is that something that most people don't
realize about Hollywood yeah you know
it's not unusual because we are we are a
storytelling you know even as as early
as being a stuntman to then becoming a
stunt coordinator in a second of
director for Joe you know you're you're
always you know I I was very fortunate I
had I had some some people that really
took me under their wing ronstein being
one of them who was like a father figure
when I first started the business and it
was like you know you can only do this
for so long as a young stunt guy you
know it's like being an athlete if you
really want to have longevity I think
you better learn lenses learn story and
and I of course I fell in love with the
fact of being a storyteller so we were
you know in some way you're always
directing you know you're always coming
up with ideas and with the relationship
I had with Joe it's like this
collaboration of when he was doing
whether it be the a-team or the gray
some of these films and you know sitting
down and talking about storyboards and
what needs to be shot it was like you're
in school you know we have a lot of
screenwriters that watch our channel
what do you think is the number one
thing screenwriters do to ruin a
screenplay that they need to really work
on I think my my thought on that Karen
is that they they spent too much time
over analyzing it and I think that
hopefully this this this newer
generation of writers is moving further
away from the kind of the let's call it
the Robert McKee story you know like
kind of this what I would I find
arguably the dearth of good writing is
this kind of is to try to plug it into
this formula this must happen at this
page that must happen at that page
because I'll find you an example
throughout the history of screenplays
that were you can confound whatever it
is that they whatever it is it's put out
there and I find that very almost
dangerously homogenizing a process which
is by its very nature spontaneous and
creative and should be I think
you when a writer stops being
spontaneous or stops allowing things to
happen to the story it's when it's
dangerous that that because it because
in doing it also siphons off the
individual nature of whomever that
writer is and when you see it done
someone like Charlie Kaufman who writes
you know masterful very unusual very
specific screenplays and that's why you
know he's regarded in the way that he is
so I think you've got to keep that in
mind and never lose sight of the fact
that you are an individual and that
screenplay should live and breathe you